so that's the Eurostar bringing people
from the continent here to London for
the Olympics and if you're in London you
can't go far without seeing these now
the Olympic rings are pretty cool but
they've joined a bit of a disappointing
way each one joined to the one next to
it it's not very creative here at
numberphile we like our rings joined and
bit more of a clever way we all know how
to rings can be linked so if I've got
one ring and I can link it with another
one and that's how I can start to form a
chain and I can't pull those two rings
apart but the cute idea of a forum owned
ring is that you end up with three rings
let's see if I can draw so that's gonna
be my first ring and my second ring
isn't linked to it see that one if I'd
filmed in the gaps would be just sitting
on top of this one and then I put a
third ring in this third ring is going
to go underneath my first one and over
my second one now if you made that out
of physical pieces of metal you'd find
that you couldn't pull it apart because
take any two of those rings and it looks
like they could be punked apart but the
third one acts as some sort of tie
joining them together in a way that they
can never be physically expanded and
I've got one here I took a course in
silver smithing some years ago so as to
make things like this and here we have
three rings to arrange it like that so
they get nice degrees to each other and
each one goes outside one ring and
inside the other but as you go around
the Rings one two three each is inside
outside outside inside and so on so that
the whole thing holds together and you
can't take them apart so this is an
example of what mathematicians calling a
higher linkage so this is a more
complicated way in which three things
can be bound together from the two rings
no two rings are linked together in this
no once you start playing with these
things you realize you can make a
corresponding entity out of any odd
number of rings it has to be odd yes it
gets a bit fiddly if you try to go
beyond five unless you're making it much
bigger the other thing that you might
want to know about it is this this is
much more familiar as a braid and
everyone knows how to braid three strips
three wires so if I had three ropes and
I braid by taking the middle one putting
it over one of the outer ones and then I
won't swap over done this wrong for
today so by that stage have swapped
everything around once I got two
overlaps under no me back to wear so if
you chase this this blue one its first
blue one so it's gone all the way up to
the other side and on the way back so
this one wasn't under this other outer
one gone all the way around here and
that to come back to its end if I now
joined it up if I song to this end to
this end and that end to that end and
that end to that end I'd have three
rings and they would be linked in
exactly the same fashion I tell you what
I take from that I think the professor's
much better at making rings than he is
at braiding hair yes if you want to see
a bit more about interlinking rings I've
actually done another video just last
week about how chemicals can link like
this as well hopefully floating there
you can see a little preview of the
video and you can click on it and
they'll also be a I'll link under the
video so have a look at that one also
so I'm here in London and I'm gonna beat
up Henry
[Laughter]